Speaker 1: Let's go next to Steve from
the San Francisco Bay area. Steve,
welcome. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 5: Hey, David, nice to talk
to you again. I was I was trying to think about
how we can get more taxes out of corporations,
you know, because historically we're at a pretty
low rate right now. And we don't also want to
disincentivize them and, you know, send them
away. I don't know if that's a real argument.
But anyways, I was thinking about an idea where
perhaps there was some sort of sliding scale as
far as the tax rate relative to corporations
profit. What do you think about that idea?
Speaker 1: You're basically just talking about
a progressive bracketed system for corporations.
Speaker 5: Yeah, basically like certain industries
of course have very high profit margins like,
um, like the beauty industry and things like
that. Others not so much, but I'm saying like,
hey, if you're making huge multiples
of your, your revenue, you know,
maybe you have a higher tax rate than a
company that's making a smaller tax area.
Speaker 1: I don't know that I would do it by
industry, but I actually think there is lower
hanging fruit. And this is something that a lot
of Democratic lawmakers have tried to go for,
which is we need to have a minimum tax for
corporations. And this has been part of a
number of different proposals. And to be
honest, I don't remember if it's part of
what Biden wants to do. The idea is you can't
deduct your way all the way down to zero taxes
the way some corporations have done. And part
of what you do is you have to eliminate certain
mechanisms as it sort of beyond the scope of this
particular recall. But, you know, before we look
into progressive tax rates for corporations,
there are very profitable corporations that pay
literally zero or have a negative tax rate that
needs to be eliminated with something equivalent
to the alternative minimum tax for businesses.
Speaker 5: Oh, yeah, for sure. You know,
places like Amazon are famous for that kind
of thing. Absolutely. Yeah. That's a very good
solution. And I can get behind that.
Speaker 1: All right, Steve,
thank you. Everything good in the Bay Area?
Speaker 5: Yeah. It's nice. In about 65 today,
enjoying the California weather?
Speaker 1: Oh, that's a great temperature.
It's hard to beat 65 in my book.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, Steve, thank you.
Speaker 3: You bet.
Speaker 1: All right. The San Francisco
Bay Area, always great to check in.